well if we can uh transition to talk
about real sports for a second yeah uh
yeah e-gaming right let's call it gaming
is that what the kids are calling it yes
uh fortnight yeah
fortnite
epic games uh has won a lawsuit against
apple i don't know how that's [ __ ]
possible good for them you don't take
down apple no also the fbi couldn't beat
apple in a lawsuit right fbi was like
can we get up in these phones
they're like go [ __ ] yourself yeah well
epic games who makes fortnite was trying
to get some bread on the side right
apple's a dealer apple's like yo if you
want to sell drugs you got to do it over
here in in amsterdam yeah right and as
long as you sell drugs on my [ __ ]
block you got to give me 30 yeah and
that's 30 of whatever comes in and their
block is the apple store so apple don't
give a [ __ ] if you got spotify if you
got any of these other apps because they
know they're getting 30 of whatever
comes in on that apple store and then
epic games fortnite was basically like
yo but we want to sell some [ __ ] within
the game
they already got it from you when you
bought it but you don't need to take
what happens in the game like we already
got this valley yeah like why are you
taking 30 that's a little crazy right
and they tried to set up their own
little um i guess like uh e-commerce
business like
almost like economy within the game you
get to buy i think v-bucks they're
called or something like that i gotta
look up the exact name and
apple was like nah you cutting that [ __ ]
down if you selling [ __ ] over here we
get a percentage right right and
this is like the digital game currency
that people use like by the sleeves and
stuff for characters etc right it's
really the first crypto when you kind of
think of it yeah it just doesn't
fluctuate in the same way but
it's a fake currency that you can use to
buy
nothing buying real things to the
consumer well i guess cryptos like nfts
are real things yeah you know what i
mean yeah
in a way right so uh so they sued and i
guess a [ __ ] judge sided with them
and this is this is kind of big because
now all these apps that were giving up
30 of whatever they made within the game
to
apple now they're all going to come out
and be like okay we're going to sell our
[ __ ] this hurts apple i'm curious
actually what happened to their stock
price after this i would assume people
are like
[ __ ] that's going to hurt their bottom
line a good amount
[Music]
they just lost not 30 of income but a
decent chunk of income because that's
their whole business strategy apple i
think their whole thing is like we're
going to lean into the apple store yeah
or the app store rather right we don't
give a [ __ ] about like creating these
different devices like we don't care
about apple music as much as we care
about the store because we'll just get a
piece of everybody's thing we'll own the
internet landscape and then whatever
happens here we'll get a little bit of
it so now we don't like a mafia boss
exactly i don't need to find my own
hustles i just need you to find hustle
and it'll make i don't need to make a
restaurant to compete with you i get a
piece of every restaurant yeah yeah
apple's down three and a half percent
interest
interesting
so i don't know i don't know what do
y'all think what is the i think it's a
valid case it was a little wild like you
i didn't once you explained it i was
like yeah you shouldn't get money on the
in-app purchases no
just because they're using they use the
apple store to buy it you get your
kickback but now
it's my app no you don't get that money
like
apple made
the avenue for you to purchase this game
i eat off that
yeah you wanted some [ __ ] to do outside
hey find a way for them to buy your game
without going through my app store well
here's the thing that's interesting they
said that you couldn't even uh include
links and stuff within your app that
would take you outside of the app store
for you to make those purchases so they
started like kicking out all those links
where they could do like in-game
purchases because they're like nah fam
you're gonna we're gonna make sure we
eat on anything that comes over here
i think it's i don't know like i
understand apple cause they're like hey
listen we're gonna create the
marketplace we're gonna put a lot of
money into the marketplace and it's
gonna be so easy for people to buy your
games we're gonna make it so simple for
them you gotta protect it against uh
hackers against this and that there's a
ton of maintenance and i just think i
just think the number's too high thirty
percent what that's just they got greedy
they agreed what if it's like thirty
percent of the app and then once you're
in game it's ten percent i don't think
any of them are balking at ten percent
but when you go thirty and it's already
in the game thirty percent of in-app i
don't know 30 of the app i don't mind
yeah you buy the app yeah
once you're inside take a smaller cut
actually if it was 10 most apps are free
so they can't make money so i'll be like
fine if my app is free and you get 10
in-app purchases it's fine but 30 no
it seems egregious right and that's the
thing what is it what is it
if without the apple store is 30 or
nothing that's true and they're hosting
your [ __ ] for free right they're not
charging nothing to host they're hosting
and then if your game happens to blow up
you got to pay off but all the games
that don't blow up they're just taking
that on the [ __ ] arm
yeah but it's like monopolistic type
[ __ ] like it's them or android and
basically you're saying we're not going
to let you have any other way on our
phone yeah so you're going to have to
give a story are you trying to say that
apple's like a shrewd businessman yeah
yeah probably i'm saying america is
going to fight against any monopolistic
[ __ ] so you're not going to have a
ballad yeah yeah we will fight against a
monopolistic practice if it hurts the
consumer that's what i've realized about
us like there's no question like amazon
is a monopolistic practice
but it helps the consumer yeah so all we
really care about is ourselves right if
we're sitting back at home and we get to
get the you know the package right if we
get to get the [ __ ] package delivered
right to our door instead of going
across the street to buy the book at
barnes noble and it's cheaper and it's
cheaper we'll do it it's just so weird
though like for example there's i have
the amazon app on my phone and i bought
i got the amazon app for free and then i
downloaded a virtual book
on the amazon app and i read the book
but i paid money to amazon for it even
though it's hosted on apple servers
you know what i mean so like i'm just
hosting on apple servers break that part
down or like the app like the amazon app
like the kindle app is on amazon servers
amazon server i'm sorry it's on apple
like i bought it through the app store
got i got you so the book that money
yeah so i did an in-app purchase through
the app store and 30 of that goes to
apple uh
is that i'm gonna right yeah so now i'm
wondering is the is the precedent that
amazon can come back and say yo we're
not giving you anything well that's why
it's a big deal yeah because once one
company is like they're getting 30 of
every purchase so like even if i buy
something through the like amazon store
if i buy groceries on the amazon app
that's what i'm wondering that's going
to happen and then my question is crazy
that's the crazy question is why are all
you're getting 30 everything yeah that
seems crazy on top of that all these
guys push their app if i was losing 30
of every in-app purchase i'd be like now
you could buy this [ __ ]
i would go so far on the right web
server they couldn't profit
because the food that you buy at whole
foods yeah is not
priced differently on amazon when you
buy it right yeah right it's not like
there's a 30 hike
that they could pay over that they can't
afford to give 30 so there has to be
something else going on that's what i'm
wondering or each company negotiates
their own deal and amazon is like you're
going to give this to us for nothing and
apple's like you're right about that or
i wonder if there's a virtual product
thing where like if it's a virtual
product that exists in your store
and there's no competition like it only
exists in your app then we get something
whereas but that's where i wonder with
like the virtual book like i'm buying a
virtual book there's no way amazon gets
thirty percent or apple is thirty
percent yeah yeah yeah it just seems so
weird but like airbnb i'm putting money
into this yeah
apple's not getting any of it they have
to get something yeah that's the
business model the cut varies
per yes yeah okay varies by the company
that's what you work out so like they
get 30 of
many digital in-app purchases yeah so
this is so what this is really a
negotiation for the percentage
they know eventually they're going to
get some sort of cut and they can't risk
it being
kicked off the apple like app store
because they'll lose too much money
anyway so they're like all right you're
gonna take a smaller percentage it's
just interesting if they won the lawsuit
then they don't have to pay any
percentage right
well if apple tries to kick them out of
the thing then couldn't they just go
back to the same judge and say they
kicked us out now i think you're allowed
to i think apple's just allowed to put
whoever they want on there yeah
you know at the end of the day it's a
private business it's not like it's a um
utility or something like that right
but uh i would love to see apple's next
move
yeah this is going to be they're
they settle outside of court and then
they can't use that as the precedent
yeah for the future [ __ ] because if it's
decision
uh
so i bet you they try to repeal the
decision yeah and then they'll settle
outside and the president's thing is
interesting like explain precedence so
basically like if a judge rules on
something to my knowledge then it can be
used as a precedent for future cases so
other companies can go look at the
decision that happened right there we
want the same ruling we want this
whereas if they settle outside even if
it's the decision that the judge would
have put forward it doesn't matter it
can't be applied
and they can put like ndas in there
we'll all find out what it is yeah but
legally speaking legally speaking there
is no precedence for them to do it
and i don't know it's just it's kind of
interesting it's like i know we put out
the [ __ ] episode the nfts are gay
whatever like that and like they don't
exist uh they're not real
but
the more that i've been like
just kind of like digesting content
understanding like what things are like
how humans interact with things
something doesn't have to be real for us
to believe it is
like we make things real and we ascribe
value to things that do not have value
right and we do this all the time and i
think that nft jump is the first time
we've done this to something that isn't
actually there
right so it's like
a a jordan sneaker
is
has no more value than like a regular
air max sneaker right in terms of like
the material used
the value is added and it's us it's the
marketing of us believing in jordan and
valuing jordan or it's the value of us
believing other people think jordan's
cool so now we do right whatever we
decide is real becomes real and has
value you've seen this happen with
diamonds you see everybody say oh the
diamonds trade is so controlled and
that's why even if they let all the
[ __ ] diamonds out
diamonds would still have some value
because of what we've put on to it we've
created the romanticism of like oh you
must be engaged with a diamond and
putting on a girl's wrist so even if you
flooded the market in the same way that
they flooded the market with money
during the pandemic even if you release
a [ __ ] stimulus of diamonds
how much did that stimulus really affect
the value of the dollar it's shocking
how there's not tons of inflation
there should be so much inflation for
the injection of capital that they put
in our economy
the fact that there was something that
there's such a minute amount
lets you know that this game is really
just a confidence game once we just go
as long as there are more goods than
there is money to buy
money will maintain a currency will it
maintain its value right and i'm
assuming they calculated that of course
like they're giving away money being
like we can inject x amount and mitigate
inflation by this amount yes but also
the most important thing is
we got to stop looking at economy as
like you have this many things you're
rich
right
it's really how many things are you
buying because when you think about it
when the pandemic hit it's not like
there was less money in the economy it's
not like we took money and burned it
when the pandemic came it was the same
amount of money there it was it's a
consumption
that shrunk yeah so they flooded the
economy so that where there would be
more consumption and that is what's
really fueling consumption and consumer
confidence and that's what's happening
with the nfts right it might not be real
but as long as the consumption is there
and the consumer confidence is there all
of a sudden it just becomes whatever
[ __ ] real is
right so it's like
i don't know i'm seeing this like nft
like hustle going on what i really think
it is is a way to like pump and dump
ethereum but you can't just say hey buy
ethereum i mean some of it is
some of it right right uh not to speak
in like complete extremes but like you
can't say buy uh buy these nfts and then
people go how do i do it oh you have to
buy ethereum to do it okay now ethereum
goes up
it's a worthy investment
if you're somebody who is a ethereum
billionaire
very worthy investment to give some some
popular
figures in social media 50 million
dollars to go buy nfts with and then
ethereum goes up 10 and you only have to
spend 2 percent of your ethereum to get
an 8 return anybody does that every day
of the week but the fact that people are
starting to buy into it and believe the
hype and want to have an nft and want to
make it their profile picture
this could be a real thing
you know it's like it's like your belief
in crypto right you may know more than
the average person about like what makes
these different cryptos valuable
barely if at all barely right but you
believe people believe that's all i
believe yes i believe people will
believe and that's all that matters yeah
you know what i'm saying like if you're
the [ __ ] like
if you're the leader of a country and
you maybe are not religious but you
believe people believe
please believe you're going to use that
religion to control some people yeah
right and that is [ __ ] crypto and
that is these nfts i will never
understand the x's and o's of pretty
much anything but i think i know people
and i think i know people are gonna
continue to believe in nfts at a larger
clip continue to believe in bitcoin at a
larger clip i just i could very well be
wrong but these are these are my hunches
i look it looks as if your hunters are
right my hunch was
and maybe i'm way more conservative with
investing in things that i can't
actually control but my hunch was like
the fcc or somebody's going to come in
here and knock this [ __ ] all out that's
a fear i have still but you know what
should kind of make you feel a little
bit better
i think enough rich people are invested
yeah and rich people dictate the
economic policy yeah not the fcc rich
people go hey buddy i got i'm up 50 on
my crypto you know whatever person who
runs the [ __ ] you know monetary
policy in america and the rest of the
western country hey we're not getting
rid of these [ __ ] coins okay yeah
it's not hurting anybody i'm a 50 i'd
like to keep that [ __ ] money so the
the more invested when visa buys an nft
like the more invested the institutions
get in crypto the more [ __ ] real and
safe it becomes
it's kind of crazy even though we all
know it's a farce
it's nothing
yeah but it [ __ ] in my mind couldn't
walk me through how this conversation
didn't happen with the dollar
hundreds of years ago i maybe in the 70s
because before that you could get gold
right oh okay okay and then once they
remove the gold standard it's like what
do
you
but here's the thing can you ever remove
a gold standard if i can just buy gold
with dollars
um
i mean yeah because then it's not pegged
yeah each thing is is varying and you
can theoretically dollar could fluctuate
when you flip the same argument for
bitcoin is like if how fake is bitcoin
if i could sell a bitcoin for 45 000.
there's a consumer for it yeah and then
the idea is eventually like they either
remove the marketplace or
enough people feel like you can't sell
it like it's made illegal in enough
places where it's like okay it's only
legal in el salvador i don't think they
got enough rich [ __ ] in el
salvador to buy the rest of our [ __ ] i'm
just saying the investment in consumer
confidence
no matter what it is a [ __ ] nft a
sleeve in a video game a [ __ ] podcast
whatever the people find valuable
if enough people find it valuable it
becomes real it doesn't matter if you
like it or not we might not like bts or
that [ __ ] kpop band we might not
understand it if enough people like it
that is popular music yeah enough people
wear baggy jeans that is the thing like
all fashion is is confidence and what
people are doing and it's like enough
taste makers doing a thing yeah
what fat it's nft it's like enough
we were taking this in the car value
jeans should be more expensive than
skinny jeans because it takes more
material
if we're just getting going off of the
material they should cost more
when they're not cool they cost less
when they are cool they cost more
right it's the consumer confidence that
dictates the price
tie fashion to this it's like every new
fashion that's ever come around like now
when skinny jeans first came i was like
this looks so [ __ ] stupid this looks
unbelievably stupid now i'm using skinny
jeans i'm looking at baggy jeans like
that looks so [ __ ] stupid what was i
thinking when i was what the [ __ ] is
that that's not a thing yeah but that's
that's what this bitcoin [ __ ] was to me
is what the [ __ ] is that's not so stupid
it's gonna go away right it's gotta go
away look what they do with fashion like
when they wanna make something cool i'm
sure the companies reach out to the
influencers they're reaching out to
bieber they're reaching out to ariana
they're reaching out to all these
different people they're like hey we
would love to put the kardashians we
want to put you in our stuff and then
all of a sudden the rest of us see that
and they go i guess this is the new cool
thing that's no different than crypto
yep
you